étranger
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le flux en direct actif numéro
50.0
, nous sommes le 17 octobre 2022 et nous
commençons la série sur
l'interoception en tant que modélisation de l'allostase en tant que contrôle,
bienvenue dans l'
institut d'inférence active, nous sommes un institut participatif en
ligne qui communique l'apprentissage
et  pratiquer l'inférence active appliquée
ceci est enregistré dans une archive en direct
, veuillez donc nous fournir des
commentaires afin que nous puissions améliorer notre travail
tous les antécédents et perspectives sont les
bienvenus et suivront une bonne
étiquette vidéo pour les flux en direct
aujourd'hui en 50.0, nous commençons cette série en
discutant  l'interception de papier comme
modélisation de l'allostase comme contrôle
les auteurs sont Eli synesh Jordan
therialt Dana Brooks John wilheim Von
DeMint Lisa Feldman Barrett et Karen s
Quigley
c'est un article publié dans la revue
biologie biologique en janvier 2022
et ce n'est qu'une introduction et un
contexte  vidéo alors que Dean ici et moi
travaillons sur cet article et discutons de
sujets connexes que
nous  Je vais passer en revue quelques grandes
questions sur les objectifs de base et la
feuille de route abstraite de l'article, puis entrer dans l'
article, toucher quelques points clés,
images et thèmes, puis
attendre principalement avec impatience d'en discuter avec les
auteurs ou toute autre personne qui aimerait  pour
rejoindre dans les semaines à venir d'
accord, donc je suis Daniel, je suis un chercheur
en Californie et
le document a été sélectionné par un vote positif décentralisé,
c'était euh amusant à lire et cela apporte de
nouveaux sujets dans notre régime d'attention,
donc je regarde  avec impatience et je
passerai à Dean
merci Charlie, je suis Dean, je suis ici à
Calgary,
je pense que ce qui est intéressant à propos de tout
papier qui, euh, tire sur
des
choses apparemment discrètes et en met quelques-uns de manière proximale et
les emmêle, puis les
sépare à nouveau  et essaie de regarder en quelque sorte
ce qui se passe lorsque les choses se combinent est
toujours quelque chose qui m'intéresse toujours,
en fait c'était le
titre de ceci et le fait
qu'ils réunissaient allostase et
teresception et quoi faire
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai passé un
peu de temps là-dessus et vraiment
je suis très intéressé d'entendre ce que les
auteurs ont à dire maintenant qu'ils ont mis
cette idée en pratique,
comment décririez-vous bien la grande
question je  signifie que je pense que l'accent est mis ici
sur ce qui se passe et sur ce que nous pouvons dire
sur les exigences du contrôleur nécessaires
pour effectuer des tâches physiologiques à des
degrés divers de complexité
euh
je n'ai jamais vraiment été sûr de la
spécificité des différents résultats et
comportements dans l'ensemble, mais  Je pense que l'
une des choses que nous pouvons dire, c'est s'il
y a une composante prédictive
et une composante de rétroaction
et qu'ils se concentrent sur deux
types particuliers de cela,
c'est intéressant peut-être quel genre de
généralités nous pouvons repartir avec
euh jamais vous savez  sorte de ne pas se
perdre dans les mauvaises herbes de bien cela s'est produit
ici et puis cela s'est produit là mais
juste à ce niveau général quel
genre de choses quand ces deux choses
sont mises ensemble
euh devrions-nous dire comme un certain modèle ou un point
commun
bien, je suis d'accord, je le mettrais dans la
catégorie de demander comment un système donné
indépendant
ou des phénomènes indépendants de la modalité comme l'
allostase qui anticipe les changements
de physiologie et se connecte à un domaine
ou un cas d'utilisation comme l'interception  et
il semble que beaucoup de modèles que
nous avons explorés ont été visuels ou
conceptuels ou symboliques
et la modalité d'interception est
apparue encore et encore dans les discussions et
c'est donc une excellente occasion d'examiner
certains formalismes pour l'interception d'
accord voici  l'article
tel que décrit précédemment quelques-uns des
faits saillants qui ont été écrits par les
auteurs sur la
page de publication l'
interception permet au cerveau d'
anticiper les besoins métaboliques à venir de l'organisme l'
interception fournit des
mesures de performance pour la régulation motrice des viscères
nous relions la théorie du contrôle à la prise de
décision et au contrôle moteur  du corps,
nous modélisons le contrôle allostatique comme un
contrôle optimal avec le temps  ing
signal de référence,
ils parlent de certaines
limitations des modèles précédents et de certains
aspects uniques de ce que fait leur modèle
et de la façon dont ils formulent le modèle apic
quelque chose à ajouter
non, je pense que leurs objectifs sont
simples, d'
accord, donc Dean et moi
cherchions à
penser  de nous-mêmes
en termes d'experts en sinistres, d'évaluateurs, d'
examinateurs et d'enquêteurs,
car nous avons
extrait toute une poignée de points vraiment
importants et saillants
dans l'argument de ce document relativement
long
et techniquement échafaudé
et extrait un tas de réclamations qui
sont écrites qui relient les points et
ensemble  certaines des interprétations euh pertinentes
pour les formalismes
voulez-vous mettre en évidence l'un d'eux ou
c'est bien de les avoir
pour quiconque veut ouais
hors de cela mais je dirai ceci ici
il y a un je pense qu'un parallèle essaie d'
être établi  ici entre le
traitement prédictif prédictif euh non je ne dis pas
que le traitement prédictif mais le
traitement comme un dispositif prédictif
et les sentiments
et le contrôle et la rétroaction et donc je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de revendications qui peuvent être
faites
mais c'est vraiment vraiment
euh nuancé et aussi un espace euh très très
complexe
dans lequel jouer et donc je peux
comprendre pourquoi
euh il y a beaucoup, beaucoup de  prétend
encore une fois si ou non ou jusqu'où ces
revendications peuvent tenir avant qu'elles
ne s'effondrent sera une chose intéressante à discuter
avec les
auteurs  J'ai beaucoup de cheveux donc c'est
difficile pour moi d'
accord
résumé d'
accord je vais lire les trois premiers
le cerveau régule le corps en
anticipant ses besoins et en essayant d'y
répondre avant qu'ils ne surviennent un processus
appelé allostase l'
allostase nécessite un modèle du
modifier les conditions sensorielles dans le
corps un processus appelé interception dans
cet article, nous examinons comment l'interoception
peut fournir une rétroaction de performance pour l'
allostase
nous suggérons d'étudier l'allostase dans te  rms
de la théorie du contrôle passant en revue les
applications des théories du contrôle aux problèmes connexes
de la physiologie du contrôle moteur et de la prise de
décision
nous les synthétisons en les reliant
aux propriétés importantes de la régulation outostatique en
tant que problème de contrôle nous
esquissons ensuite un formalisme normal pour la façon dont le
cerveau pourrait effectuer le contrôle allostatique
de  les viscères par analogie, deux
contrôles moteurs squelettiques, y compris une
vue mathématique et comment l'intersection agit comme un
retour de performance pour l'allostase,
enfin, nous suggérons des moyens de tester les
implications de notre hypothèse
sur la feuille de route
commence par une introduction à la
fonction
du cerveau dans le corps
, puis  présente certains des
piliers ou fondements clés de leur
synthèse et de leur interprétation, à savoir la
théorie du contrôle d'interception en tant qu'approche pour
unifier la prise de décision de contrôle moteur physiologique
et l'allostase en tant que
suivi de trajectoire contrôle optimal stochastique
la cinquième section est une discussion,
puis il y a une annexe B et
Californie  et dans leurs mots, quatre sections de cet
article relient l'interception à l'allostase la
section deux établit comment l'
interoception permet au cerveau d'
estimer l'efficacité physiologique
du corps au moment présent, ce qui est
précisément ce qu'il a besoin de savoir pour
évaluer et affiner l'action La
section 3 introduit le contrôle  théorie la
section 4 applique les principes de
la théorie du contrôle pour dériver un nouveau
modèle de format de la façon dont le cerveau pourrait estimer
la désirabilité des
trajectoires physiologiques et prendre
des décisions réglementaires prospectives enfin la section 5
synthétise les trois sections précédentes
pour explorer les implications directes
du formalisme proposé annexe a
fournit un glossaire des termes mais ceci est
déplacé vers le haut et ce n'est plus une annexe
donc il n'y a pas d'annexe une
annexe B1 fournit des
détails mathématiques liés à la section 3 et l'
annexe C1 fournit des
détails mathématiques liés à la section 4.
les mots-clés étaient
allostase d'interception et traitement prédictif
nous  je vais  pour parler beaucoup d'
interception et d'allostase
un peu dans ce point zéro mais certainement
dans les discussions à venir et pour le
traitement prédictif, un bon
flux récent est le flux en direct numéro 43 avec
Maria d'
accord aussi juste pour référence, nous ferons une
pause juste assez longtemps pour vous  pour les
capturer si vous voulez,
il y a un tableau de nomenclature
avec la définition de nombreux mots, donc
voici les premiers termes de nomenclature 1
à 25.
et puis voici la seconde moitié de la
nomenclature 26 à 49.
triez par ordre alphabétique
tout ce qu'il faut ajouter sur la nomenclature
autre que  pour dire que
c'est bien qu'ils l'aient fourni et
qu'il sera utilisé dans les sections à venir,
je pense qu'il est intéressant que vous ayez
souligné que le euh ils ont tiré, ils ont
tiré les définitions vers l'avant, puis
quand vous regardez les formalismes et donc je
pense  du point de vue de
ce qu'ils veulent faire passer autour de
cela,
ce
tressage nous oblige à au moins avoir un
bon sens autour de ce que les choses signifient
avant  nous commençons
à essayer de séparer ce qu'ils égalent,
alors oui, j'ai un peu ce genre de choses comme ça
bien dit d'
accord section un introduction les
fonctions du cerveau dans le corps d'
accord
il y a un début évocateur à cet
article
euh jouer à un simple jeu de ballon chasseur
alors  nécessite que votre cerveau
coordonne continuellement les systèmes de votre corps
et ce motif de ballon chasseur va
revenir
et sur la gauche se trouve un visage enlacé
mise en œuvre d'un
algorithme de diffusion stable L'invite de l'image était
DodgeBall fourmis ludiques inférence active
principe d'énergie libre
et pendant que nous faisions les diapositives, nous
étions engagés dans une inférence active avec
certaines de ces affordances génératrices d'images
et permettant à cela de bien
faire ce que
je pense que c'est vraiment intéressant
que ce que ce que le générateur a dit
ce serait le résultat d'un
euh coordonné
quel est le  mot Je cherche un
enchevêtrement de ces invites
mais je n'ai rien dit sur quelle
stratégie chacune de  ceux que
Silhouettes emploie maintenant
et je pense qu'il y a un
sentiment implicite qu'il y a une stratégie en
cours également, donc encore une fois, lorsque vous réunissez certaines de
ces choses vraiment intéressantes,
je suppose que cela dépend de la profondeur à laquelle vous
voulez aller  vous voulez
dimensionner l'espace
alors qu'est-ce que c'est là ouais c'est
la même invite c'était juste un autre
celui-ci vient plus un peu plus
photoréaliste
un peu plus comme
insaisissable vous savez sont-ils en train de jouer au
ballon chasseur
ouais
sont-ils juste en train de déduire d'
accord  mot-clé suivant, vous pouvez y aller
si vous ne pouvez lire que la
définition ici, mais donnez simplement votre propre avis sur
ce qu'est l'interception,
je pense qu'en fin de
compte, il y a une certaine quantité de
signaux de signalisation en cours dont nous
devenons conscients  de parfois les jeunes
ou toutes les personnes aiment les
catégoriser tous sous le parapluie des sentiments
et euh
j'ai attrapé ça des tots On Target juste
parce que j'ai toujours travaillé dans t  ce genre d'
espace de comment pouvons-nous garder cela aussi simple
que possible et donc lorsque vous obtenez ces
signaux, ces signaux sensoriels proviennent
de l'intérieur du corps, ce sont les
sentiments que vous ressentez et euh si
vous les connectez ou non au monde extérieur de
votre
la peau ou vos marges
euh parfois vous le faites parfois vous ne
vous réveillez pas avec un mal de ventre,
alors qu'est-ce que cela signifie aujourd'hui,
bien,
je dirais qu'une interception un peu étroite
fait référence à une
observation et à une inférence sur des États cachés
avec un référent  c'est dans le tarot à l'intérieur
du corps par opposition au tarot X
à l'extérieur du corps, mais il y a probablement
aussi beaucoup de flou et ce que
fait vraiment la rétine, c'est qu'elle fait des
inférences sur elle-même et où fait-elle
réellement des inférences sur la
structure du monde extérieur tout  bons
modèles internes interceptifs, vous avez ajouté quelques images, alors
quelles sont-
elles, je vais donc lire ce très rapidement afin que les
psychologues se réfèrent au mod interne,
y compris l'interception par de nombreux termes et
Je pense que je pense que c'est important
parce qu'il n'y a pas toujours eu d'
accord sur la définition claire de ce qu'est un
modèle interne,
euh des choses comme l'intérêt inconscient
semblent s'inscrire dans ce parapluie de
simulation incarnée Concepts et catégories
contrôlées hallucination qui était nouvelle
pour moi parce que je ne '  Je ne sais même pas ce que
cela signifie euh et peu importe comment
on l'appelle, le cerveau est supposé
construire un modèle dynamique de son corps
dans le monde.
en termes d'
abduction, le signal a interprété
l'objet
euh quel est ce modèle comment pouvons-nous comment
éviter d'entrer dans un autre grand
débat sur la question de savoir si c'est
représentatif et rempli de contenu ou
non ou y a-t-il quelque chose que
nous
ressentons de l'intérieur chaque chaque chaque
des données ponctuelles nous parviennent et
sont déversées
sur nos différentes surfaces sensorielles
extérieur extérieur à l'extérieur
Je pense qu'il y a un morceau qui
vient de l'extérieur je sais quand la
température monte dans la pièce mais ma
température peut aussi monter
parce que j'ai mangé une mauvaise crevette et c'est
parfois difficile de
savoir si c'est parce que la chaleur est
partie  ou si mon corps réagit
avec un geste inflammatoire
ouais c'est un
bon point comme parfois appelé une
différence faisant la cause ou la différence
qui fait une différence est-ce qu'une infection virale fait
augmenter la température corporelle
et ou dans quelle mesure cela peut-il être
décomposé en facteurs de  le virus
par rapport à cela, la dynamique changeant du
système immunitaire,
une
image si intéressante sur la gauche sait que je
ne peux pas dire si l'image de gauche
par l'image de gauche quelle est la
vitesse à laquelle l'image de droite se
déplace réellement sur la route et  c'est un peu
pourquoi je voulais l'ambiguïté là
pour un modèle d'entérocepteur parce que vous
savez que demacio parle beaucoup de ce que
pouvons-nous vraiment
décrire et poursuivre pr  des termes précis et
ce qui reste quelque peu ambigu et les
auteurs de cet article parlent aussi un peu
de Dieu ouais quand le référent
est externe c'est objectif alors il y a
la possibilité pour de multiples
perspectives externes de s'aligner sans même dire
que c'est mieux mais juste la possibilité
de tandis que  si le comportement incarné de
votre point de consigne physiologique pour une
régulation physiologique
est modifié, il n'a plus la même
possibilité d'alignement externe
pour le meilleur et pour le pire
et presque toujours avec difficulté à
communiquer ou parfois à mesurer également en
laboratoire et à citer le
contrôle
Donc  parler avec les auteurs à ce sujet et pourquoi
ils étudient cette modalité
sera très intéressant en ce qui concerne les
phénomènes informatiques ou indépendants du système
qu'ils vont essayer d'intégrer
avec Alice avec l'intersection est l'
allostase ils définissent ce terme comme l'
allostase est d'anticiper  l'évolution des
besoins évaluer les priorités et préparer
l'organisation  sm pour les satisfaire avant qu'ils ne
conduisent à des erreurs un processus appelé
allostase alors disons simplement que vous
avez un modèle allostatique de la
température dans la pièce
et que la température corporelle centrale ne
change pas, alors peut-on regarder en arrière et dire que
ce n'est pas le cas  changer parce qu'on s'attendait
à ce qu'il change
et quelqu'un dira simplement comment savez-
vous que cela a fonctionné alors parce que cela
n'a pas augmenté la température corporelle,
je me suis concentré sur le fait
qu'ils le décrivent comme un processus en trois parties,
donc moi étant  parlant toujours de ce qui est
le minimum ici, quel est le minimum ici dont
nous avons besoin pour pouvoir faire
cela, je trouve que ce n'est vraiment pas très
intéressant
pourquoi trois
pas quatre ou cinq le divisent
en tranches plus petites, c'est encore
une autre de celles-ci  questions que
j'aimerais pouvoir parler aux auteurs de
toutes les bonnes inférences actives
qu'ils ont écrites
avant de
plonger dans les détails de la modélisation formelle
ci-dessous, auxquels nous reviendrons plus tard
dans l'article,
il pourrait être utile de  comparez et
mettez en contraste l'approche ici apic avec l'inférence active du cadre de modélisation proéminent et nous allons
revenir sur certains de ces détails et je suis
sûr d'avoir beaucoup de discussions à ce sujet, mais
vous avez fait un point très intéressant dans
notre préparation sur la façon dont  ils ne
traitent pas leur modèle comme en
aval ou comme un corollaire de tout
engagement envers une physique particulière,
c'est ainsi que nous entendons souvent parler du
principe de l'énergie libre, essentiellement de la mécanique,
mais ils traitent plutôt
le
modèle comme une construction de premier ordre
tout ce que vous voulez ajouter  cela parce que
je pensais que c'était vraiment comme m'aider à
encadrer le sujet de l'article
ouais c'est une partie de la rue, je pense que la
balle de travail contrairement à la plupart des
modèles d'intérêt actif dans la littérature est le
matériel ci-dessous considère un
temps indéfini ou un réglage de contrôle Horizon infini
est intéressant parce que  cela rend
vraiment très clair entre ce dont ils
parlent et ce que nous voyons souvent dans
beaucoup de représentations qui est t0
T1 à T
quoi qu'il
en soit en termes de capacité à comprendre
ce qui se passe de manière séquentielle, donc
très bien
cette section de l'introduction parle
de certains problèmes avec d'autres modèles,
ils parlent de la façon dont les modèles d'
interception existants ont soit formulé l'
allostase comme une
décision prospective-  faire un problème
sans considérer comment ces décisions
sont mises en œuvre, ce qui a un tas d'
interprétations différentes, mais peut-être par
exemple nécessitant l'énumération des
politiques, puis la sélection des
politiques
ou comme un problème de contrôle moteur sans
considérer d'où viennent les commandes motrices
d'
un autre problème qu'ils ont avec d'autres
modèles plutôt que de traiter l'
efficacité métabolique comme l'objectif dont ils discutent l'
homéostasie la régulation des
variables corporelles pour fixer des points de consigne avec une
tolérance d'erreur fixe,
donc cela va vraiment être un
thème cool qui est
plutôt que de fixer le point de consigne et la
variabilité
voir ce résultat comme  étant dû à un
autre processus qui entraîne une
attra  définir un ensemble ou un point avec un
point de consigne fixe et une tolérance empirique à l'
erreur ainsi que peut-être des points de non-
retour, etc.,
mais voir tous ces résultats comme la
réalisation d'un système dynamique
qui ne poursuit pas un point de consigne mais
plutôt  poursuit une pente sur un graphique que
nous allons explorer et qui, comme la zone de
contrôlabilité maximale
et la réduction de la surprise autour de la
zone de contrôlabilité maximale au
cours du temps évolutif, sera
associée à ce type de variable de survie
et à d'autres points d'accord, quoi que ce soit d'autre
eh bien, c'est une relation
relationnelle et ensuite ils disent que cet
article vise à combler cet écart
Je pense que dans une relation n'implique pas
nécessairement que les choses doivent
être
fermées en termes de quel que soit l'écart
en comblant quelque chose je pense que
le fait qu'ils  parler de ciblage,
je pense au fait qu'ils voient la
relation comme
jouant un rôle clé dans ce qu'ils pensent qu'il
se passe ici
euh signifie que  qu'ils peuvent peut-être que l'
écart continue, je veux dire qu'ils
mettent des choses ici pour que nous les examinions
et les contemplions, mais je ne suis pas sûr
si nous comblons réellement un vide où
nous comprenons juste ce qu'il y a
dedans  espacez
la
section droite deux donc au début de la
section deux, l'
interception des paragraphes du haut modélise le
corps en estimant son efficacité, puis
la section ci-dessous le
pli 2.5 le résumé donc les deux
avant et après 2.
um 2.0
2.2
contient beaucoup d'informations structurelles
sur  les points clés de cet article
quoi que ce soit à ajouter sur cette diapositive spécifique
ou nous irons simplement dans les sections
étoile tout en bas là-bas, les
gens voudront peut-être avoir une lecture à ce sujet
parce que je pense que c'est et cela dit
que c'est controversé mais  Je pense qu'il
est intéressant ouais
euh que le mouvement vers
la plage de réponse d'une courbe de capacité
pourrait potentiellement éviter le besoin
d'un circuit ou d'un module neuronal dédié
qui calcule spécifiquement le
les constructions comportementales des coûts de récompense,
alors qu'est-ce
que cela signifie de passer à une compréhension
non centrée sur la récompense
de la physiologie
ou de réinterpréter la récompense d'
accord, la section 2.1 introduit une
distinction qui sera essentielle dans
le reste de l'article qui est la
différence entre deux types  de
variables sensorielles viscérales interceptives
celles qui représentent des quantités de
ressources les ressources régulées et celles
qui représentent les taux auxquels les
processus agissent les processus contrôlés
les ressources régulées sont maintenues stables
relativement stables dans le temps, les exemples
incluent la glycémie et la température corporelle centrale, il
est
donc à noter qu'ils n'ont pas  être une
ressource épuisable la
ressource régulée est un peu comme
la variable bornée dans une physiologie dans
un contexte d'homéostasie ce n'est pas
nécessairement une ressource épuisable comme un métabolite
euh une ressource régulée comme la glycémie
ou la température corporelle centrale représente une
quantité physique ou une substance comme le
glucose sa quantité  ne peut pas changer
instantanément donc je  pense qu'il sera
intéressant de demander
quelles sont les différentes ressources régulées
de différentes modalités
, puis les processus contrôlés
sont les taux auxquels les
processus physiologiques fonctionnent, donc dans ce cas, ce
serait comme le type de
relations d'entrée-sortie de la glycémie d'
accord ouais nous parlons juste  à ce sujet, nous en
avons parlé récemment est quelle est la
différence entre la pince et la poignée et
peuvent tous deux exister à la fois
belle
2.2 retour à l'exemple DodgeBall la
fréquence cardiaque et la pression artérielle doivent
augmenter pendant l'exercice aérobie comme
indiqué dans l'exemple DodgeBall
donc il doit  être une
adaptation physiologique afin de commencer à faire de l'exercice et de
continuer à faire
de l'exercice dans des conditions de repos, le barorécepteur
qui est le réflexe de fréquence cardiaque du récepteur de pression
contrecarrerait normalement toute augmentation
de la pression artérielle en ralentissant le
rythme cardiaque, mais avec l'effort, votre
tension artérielle et votre fréquence cardiaque doivent
augmenter pour soutenir le  besoin d'augmentation
du flux sanguin requis par votre
ex  exercer les muscles
et donc ensuite il y a une discussion sur la façon dont
ce type de modulation du réflexe
permet euh le déplacement d'une fonction entière
reliant un changement de pression artérielle à un
changement de votre fréquence cardiaque,
donc cela décrit comme une
approche de systèmes dynamiques et un modèle physiologique
pour  comment la structure causale ou corrélationnelle
de différentes
variables physiologiques peut être modélisée de
manière assez générale, mais cela va devenir
plus spécifique
ouais un peu de covariation là
et euh
et Physiologie et c'est parti
2.2 prédire et modéliser les
gammes de processus régulés et contrôlés
ceci  décrit certains des
paramètres
de
la Courbe
le seuil et les points de saturation
qui dérivent en partie Définir des courbes qui
sont dérivées de fonctions
que les physiologistes utilisent couramment pour
modéliser le lien entre les
perturbations et les réponses de régulation en les
nommant généralement courbes de réponse ou
fonctions de transfert
, puis le terme capacité  courbes
seront utilisées pour souligner  e le fait que, bien que
ces courbes puissent évoluer dans le temps
à tout instant, elles représentent la
gamme actuelle de
ressources réglementaires limitées disponibles pour un organisme, de
sorte que l'on pourrait imaginer comme une
courbe de capacité financière pour maintenir un
marché à un moment donné comme un peu comme
la profondeur
mais par
analogie
et puis cette
idée de modélisation de la façon dont un système répond
aux perturbations
ne nécessite pas nécessairement de modéliser le
modèle interne de ce système, mais au fur et à mesure que vous
construisez un meilleur modèle génératif du
système perturbé que les meilleures
expériences et plus vous pouvez  euh
ont une sorte de perturbabilité du
système, cela vous permet d'approcher votre
système sans hypothèse forte sur
sa structure
la courbe de capacité de la figure deux points
ou de la figure un a la
forme mathématique, puis la figure un est montrée à
côté de l'équation un
les paramètres sont  défini la fonction
y est uh en prenant U mu K étant R Big B
et en combinant ceux-ci dans une équation
le chiffre un sur  l'axe des x montre
la pression artérielle
, puis l'axe des y montre le
pourcentage d'activation de base du
réflexe modulant cette
variable physiologique, donc à 100, qui est la
pression artérielle cible ou une sorte de ce qu'on
appellerait le point de consigne homéostatique car
il  semble être un attracteur
à ce moment-là, l'activation de base
du réflexe barillet se produit
lorsque la pression artérielle augmente, puis
le réflexe barillet s'active jusqu'à 2x
seuillage à 2x activation de la
ligne de base, puis lorsque la pression artérielle
diminue le réflexe barillet à nouveau avec
ce sigmoïde  la symétrie diminue
c'est un modèle dynamique de régulation
des
équations de pression artérielle 2 3 et 4.
décrire la forme d'un modèle génératif une
procédure pour
prédire de manière probabiliste les variables observées en termes
de variables non observées
les variables répertoriées sont des variables non observées
qui sont échantillonnées à partir d'une
probabilité A Priory  la distribution ne
dépend pas des données,
donc cela fait référence à l'utilisation d'un
générateur  modèle ive et comment ces équations le
constituent
la variable quantile
représente uniformément la relation entre la
pression artérielle et l'
activation du réflexe baril indépendamment des changements
du point de fonctionnement de la courbe de capacité mu
et du gain K le quantile dépend uniquement de
la forme fonctionnelle de la
courbe de capacité et non des paramètres donc nous allons
décompresser  c'est un peu plus techniquement
mais ils soulignent que comme caractéristique de
leur modèle
ici encore est la figure un un peu plus grande
avec plus d'espace pour discuter plus tard et
voici la figure deux
qui est la courbe de capacité de la figure
un en bleu avec une réponse linéarisée
en Orange
autour du point de fonctionnement le
marqueur Blue Diamond
afin que l'
on puisse voir cela comme la pente positive maximale
de cette courbe sigmoïde
et  que sous
la spécification
que le réflexe va être activé
de manière sigmoïde
puis selon que l'on est comme
une partie courbée vers le haut ou une partie courbée vers le bas
ou que l'on y pense comme poursuivant la
pente positive maximale
puis poursuivant ce point et étant
récompensé  par des mouvements vers une
maniabilité et un contrôle maximum
équivaudrait à poursuivre un
modèle homéostatique où cela ressemble à un
attracteur à point fixe,
donc il met le type de fond du
bol
dans cette ligne orange maximisée en
pente plutôt que le diamant bleu étant
réduit en  sa distance par rapport à 100. à
droite,
je pense que nous avons copié cette
section deux fois,
c'était tellement inhabituel que nous l'avons copiée deux fois
ouais 2.3
revenons à l'exemple DodgeBall
et ils vont élargir leur champ d'application
Au-delà de la pression artérielle réflexe Barrow
aux niveaux circulants d'oxygène glucose
et le dioxyde de carbone,
nous nous concentrons ensuite sur le glucose sanguin en tant que
ressource régulée avec le glucagon en tant que
processus contrôlé permettant la sécrétion de
le glucose dans le sang et l'insuline en tant que
processus de contrôle permettant l'élimination du
glucose du sang, de sorte que le réflexe du baril
était comme un bouton de volume unique
ou une infirmière de triage qui peut abaisser ou
augmenter la réponse unique, donc si une
variable physiologique est élevée, c'est comme si
elle pouvait  être comme si
la régulation du glucose supprimée avait plusieurs hormones,
ça va être comme tamponné de deux
côtés différents d'une manière légèrement différente
, mais en utilisant beaucoup des mêmes
formalismes et logiques
pour introduire un système
physiologique légèrement différent et plus complexe d'
accord,
la section discute de certaines découvertes
que les taux de glycémie dans le sang ne sont pas
activement défendus à un
point de consigne biologiquement codé en dur, pas plus que la
fréquence cardiaque n'est plutôt le glucagon et l'activité de deux
hormones de l'insuline
équilibrent les effets de l'autre pour
amener la glycémie à un point
dans sa plage de stabilisation
avec le glucose entrant dans le  sang après que
la personne a ingéré de la nourriture et du glucose, puis le
passage du sang dans d'autres
corps  tissus pour soutenir leur fonction
quoi que ce soit à ajouter sur cette
diapositive, pas spécifiquement maintenant, attendez que
nous arrivions à la fin de la section les
deux deuxièmes trucs
donc voici la figure trois
ils écrivent la figure trois
montre les tracés des fonctions résultantes
de cette équation
appliquée à  le cas de l'insuline
qui peut être interprété comme des
courbes de capacité le sigmoïde orange est l'insuline
le sigmoïde bleu est le glucagon
ils ont différents niveaux d'hormones à
différents axes x qui est le niveau de
glucose dans le sang et donc vous
voyez un comportement familier lorsque le glucose est
élevé  alors l'insuline est à haute sécrétion
qui entraîne l'absorption du glucose
et lorsque le glucose devient bas dans ce cas en
dessous de 2,5 ou 3 environ, alors le
glucagon est sécrété pour inciter le glucose
à pénétrer dans le sang
et on peut donc imaginer que le taux de
glucose oscillera  dans cet espace
mais pas exactement
fixé à un point de consigne avec un résidu étant
minimisé la
section 2.4
est l'endroit où ils s'éloignent de la discussion de ce
type de mo réglementaire  del
euh dans des plages et des capacités viables
pourrait éviter un système de récompense modulaire
voici un argument ou un appel à la
neuroanatomie il n'y a pas de site cérébral unique
qui code spécifiquement la
valeur de renforcement appétitif ou aversif il est utile de recadrer les
systèmes de récompense et de décision discrets en tant que domaine
Systèmes de contrôle allostatiques généraux
le  la généralité du domaine de l'interception
fournit un soutien théorique supplémentaire à
l'idée que nous n'avons pas besoin de
modules mentaux ou de facultés psychologiques Concepts
pour comprendre comment un cerveau fonctionne
un compte rendu mathématiquement valable et biologiquement
plausible du contrôle allostatique
ne nécessite pas de
système de récompense modulaire ou séparé dans le système central  système nerveux
et un peu plus sur ce sujet rien à
ajouter
maintenant passons à 37. d'
accord les récompenses du contrôle donc ici
je voulais mettre en évidence deux articles avec de
belles images
par les deux articles impliquant Tobias Norville
et ces articles sont cités dans l'article
en cours de discussion et ils montrent tous une
jolie inte  caractéristiques de repos, donc juste pour
mettre en évidence certains de ces
graphiques, voici les mouvements dans un
espace de glucose et de température, donc la régulation de
plusieurs variables physiologiques
ici en bas à gauche est l'
intégration du
point de consigne homéostatique d'interception et des commandes motrices comme
liées à la recherche de nourriture,
voici quelques
visualisations bayésiennes avec  une improbabilité postérieure antérieure
et à propos de cette
relation bidirectionnelle d'inférence et d'un ancien
modèle dynamique l'histoire de deux
densités, puis la dernière c'est euh
une autre approche de modélisation de la température corporelle et du glucose
qui aboutit à cette notion que nous
décrivons comme allant vers le bas  du
bol
où la forme de cette
serviette
pourrait être conçue ou évoluée ou sélectionnée de
sorte que le marbre passe la plupart de son
temps dans une certaine zone et c'est
comme une autre façon de penser à
ces types de systèmes d'attracteurs
plutôt que comme des traces  ou ainsi de suite d'
accord quoi que ce soit à ajouter,
je pense que la section deux
confirme essentiellement que si vous allez t  o
faire n'importe quel type de performance prédictive
qui a un élément de
continuité qui dépend d'une sorte de
limites finies reconnaissables et aussi de la
variabilité dans quelles que soient ces limites
et je pense que ça
parle en quelque sorte de l'idée qu'il y a
dans un dans  une sorte de situation à deux facteurs,
il y a un signal qui ressemble à ceci
et ils ont en quelque sorte souligné quelques
exemples du réflexe du baril et du
et du glucagon et
ils essayaient également d'éviter de
trop simplifier ou de trop réduire comme
ils essayaient de  garder
la complexité de ces deux exemples
retenus en termes de ce qu'ils
essayaient de retenir est quelque chose qui
nous permet de commencer à regarder ces
courbes de capacité
bien section trois théorie
du contrôle la lentille unificatrice pour le contrôle moteur physiologique
et la prise de décision
et puis un  de leurs résumés du
chapitre, cette section
présente les concepts de la
théorie du contrôle technique, puis passe en revue ses
applications dans les sciences de la vie.
inclure la section physiologie 3.1
la section 3.2 du mouvement moteur squelettique et la
section 3.3 de la prise de décision la section 3.4
reliera les futurs états d'interception aux
mouvements actuels.
pour
suggérer comment l'interception prend en charge l'
allostase d'
accord ici, nous n'allons pas
tout lire sur la diapositive, mais cela vient de la
section 3.1 théorie du contrôle pour la
physiologie un corps fiable un corps fiable
construit à partir de pièces non fiables quoi que ce soit à
ajouter sur ce non les
gens veulent juste lire ceci  oui, je vais
juste demander à un contrôleur de
bien fonctionner, il doit contenir une sorte
de copie ou de miroir du comportement attendu de la plante
qui est
appelé un modèle interne que
les théoriciens du contrôle appellent aider le
système entraîné à planter et sa
trajectoire souhaitée la référence  trajectoire
et il y a une discussion intéressante
sur ce genre de euh
fil de la théorie du contrôle
figure quatre
donc la figure quatre est un
schéma fonctionnel du système de contrôle basé sur un modèle
l'usine d'Orange est l'objet ou le
système dont le mouvement ou un autre comportement est
contrôlé
le contrôleur violet envoie des signaux
contrôle les flèches pleines
le changement comment l'usine se déplace  et
signale les prédictions de résultats attendus
flèche jaune pleine vers l'
estimateur d'état en jaune et ainsi de suite les gens peuvent
lire le reste
pour ces chiffres Daniel à mesure que nous avançons
dans les diapositives pourquoi je ne
lis pas et ensuite vous pouvez exécuter le curseur
sur les différentes parties du modèle afin que les
gens puissent en quelque sorte voir et voir en temps réel
comment les deux choses s'alignent
bien, nous le ferons pour les futures
et cela va
révoquer ou euh rappeler
celle de nos discussions précédentes en
direct  23 performance habile et
interactionnisme et instructionisme et
comment penser aux plantes motrices et ainsi
de suite
section droite 3.2 déplacer le corps l'
hypothèse de contrôle de référence de sorte que le
hypothèse de contrôle de référence les
citations fournies étaient à Feldman 2015
et latash 2021
et l'hypothèse de contrôle de référence
décrit le système moteur squelettique en
termes d'une hiérarchie de contrôleurs avec
des contrôleurs de niveau supérieur dans le cerveau
prescrivant des trajectoires de référence aux
réflexes de niveau inférieur dans la moelle
épinière ces  les réflexes comparent ensuite la
longueur réelle du muscle signalée
par les neurones propriocepteurs afférents à la
longueur de référence envoyée par le cerveau
et contractent le muscle pour mettre les
deux en accord et voici donc la
partie supérieure de la table des matières du
livre de Feldman 2015  le contrôle référent de l'
action et de la perception et l'article de
latash en physique de la vie revue 2021
avec quelques graphiques autour de ce type d'
approche
étrangère
vous pouvez commencer avec cette diapositive sur le
monde réel d'
accord eh bien je vais juste souligner quelques
choses que les auteurs disent  parce qu'ils
ne veulent pas être accusés d'une sorte de
surentraînement ici,
démarrez votre contrôle moteur  l'expérience n'est
qu'un chevauchement limité avec la
structure réelle du contrôle moteur, donc
seule une expérience de chevauchement limité sur les
comportements d'atteinte implique qu'un
expérimentateur prescrive la
tâche d'atteinte aux participants le
cerveau des participants ne fonctionne pas spécifiquement pour
suivre les instructions d'un expérimentateur
mais plutôt pour réguler leur propre corps
le  l'organisation réelle
du système nerveux central se produit mieux avec une
vue à l'envers du
mouvement de la fonction motrice du corps, c'est-à-dire la
régulation somatique des voies somatomotrices
du corps, par exemple dans le jeu avec la
valeur Dr si vous marchez de manière inattendue sur un
bloc dur ou pointu ou  objet, vous
ne vous empalez généralement pas intentionnellement qui a
marché dessus, alors je voulais juste passer
par mon pied maintenant
parce que je pourrais me concentrer toujours sur la
stabilisation de ma posture gravité avec bobine
et douleur que vous ressentez de manière interceptive
et la perturbation imprévue de tout
les lésions tissulaires vous obligent à prendre une
décision sur ce qu'il faut faire ensuite  e
vous-même pour soigner votre pied ou jouer à
travers cette douleur,
je pense que le fait qu'ils essaient de
limiter ce qu'ils disent est la
mesure dans laquelle l'objectif de cela
peut être considéré comme une bonne chose
parce que je pense qu'il y a un  quelques
zones
autour,
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans cette relation entre
un système de commande ou un système de contrôle et
un système de demande où faire des choses
comme quand votre corps
commence à souffrir d'hypothermie légère
et et vous savez que les gens savent que
votre cerveau cesse de fonctionner correctement
euh comment faites-vous la différence entre par
exemple
euh j'ai un mal de tête Slurpee et
vous posez le Slurpee et arrêtez de le
boire parce que vous savez que c'est
l'effet par rapport à vos membres
qui ne sont pas gelés à
ce stade ou à  du moins, espérons-le, pas pour
nous, continuez à bouger pour que vous
ne vous arrêtiez pas, vous évitez d'arrêter de
bouger tous ensemble, ce qui
est essentiellement la mort, alors ici, nous nous
demandons si oui ou non
euh w  sans entrer dans l'argument
parce qu'il est assez évident que si votre
cerveau est mort, vous êtes mort mais si vos
mains sont mortes ou et que vous êtes toujours en
vie, cette distinction claire entre une
conséquence du centre de commande et une
conséquence du centre de demande qu'est-ce que cela signifie
en termes  d'accord, donc il y a des choses qui
se produisent que vous faites automatiquement
afin de vous maintenir en vie dans certaines des
situations les plus critiques et ce n'est
pas comme la vôtre, votre
votre main a le cerveau et pourtant, il
peut simplement se déplacer Au-delà d'une
chose réflexive être  capable de vous garder en
vie assez longtemps jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un vienne
à votre secours en tant que par exemple,
donc je ne sais pas si c'est déroutant ou
non, mais je pense qu'il y a une
réconciliation, mais cela se passe entre l'
ordre et la demande et peut-être un peu de
contrôle  est la capacité d'abandonner les
temps commandés afin
qu'une nouvelle réponse prenne le relais et vous maintienne en
vie et vous ne savez peut-être pas nécessairement
comment faire cela à partir d'un
centre de commandement, alors nous '  Je dois en parler aux
auteurs parce que ce sont des
questions que je me pose parce que j'ai un
peu de connaissances physiologiques, donc je
m'interroge sur ces situations extrêmes, d'
accord,
section 33, prendre des décisions, construire
des trajectoires de référence futures,
ils utilisent le mot demande, alors
nous '  J'en reparlerai plus tard ouais plus de
citations de trois trois pour ceux qui
veulent faire une capture d'écran
parlant de l'ergonomie qui est également
soulevée dans l'annexe B sur laquelle nous
n'allons pas nous concentrer d'
accord, vous pouvez lire la figure cinq et
j'utiliserai la souris  euh donc un
schéma fonctionnel pour une expérience
psychologue expérimental vue orientée tâche du
contrôle moteur le schéma montre une structure logique formelle
ici
à un niveau conceptuel les cases et les
flèches ne correspondent pas à l'anatomie
du cerveau ou du système nerveux contrairement
à la figure quatre  le diagramme fait la
distinction entre le cerveau moteur squelettique
et les contrôleurs de réflexe d'étirement périphérique
et entre les
estimateurs d'état sensoriel cerveau et périphérie  al
organes sensoriels surfaces sensorielles surfaces sensorielles
le diagramme montre une
perspective d'ingénierie
importante à noter que sur une
expérience de psychologie dans laquelle l'expérimentateur
prescrit une tâche pour le comportement aux
participants donc il y a une externalité
et le cerveau d'un participant agit alors comme un
système de contrôle pour atteindre le comportement
les
systèmes de comportement prescrits qui maintiennent le corps servent donc des
systèmes qui déplacent le corps
qui à leur tour servent un comportement prescrit,
alors concentrez-vous à nouveau sur le
prescriptif, l'externalité, les
informations entrant dans la
bonne
fonction de l'ordinateur portable ouais, un
schéma fonctionnel pour une
vue théorique de contrôle  d'allostase contrairement
à la figure cinq, ce diagramme montre un
système de contrôle en boucle fermée conçu pour
la régulation autonome du corps et
les comportements de tâche souhaités de l'expérimentateur
remplacés par ou par désolé l'
estimateur de capacité allostatique
qui envoie des prédictions de courbes de capacité
que nous avons déjà examinées
la réception intérieure  ive State estimateur
et reçoit les erreurs de prédiction avec
lesquelles mettre à jour ses estimations
les estimations mises à jour sont émises comme un
signal de référence pour le contrôleur moteur du visiteur
ce diagramme montre une
structure logique formelle un niveau conceptuel l'
hypothèse représentée est contrainte par
les structures anatomiques déduites dans
Bear 2017  mais les cases et les flèches ne mappent
pas
une répétition ne mappent pas une à une sur l'
anatomie du cerveau ou du système nerveux
très
bien, donc juste pour souligner la différence ici,
la gauche est presque comme un
instructeur
Arrangements et c'est ainsi que le
psychologue expérimental  pense à
cette tâche qui est comme si nous écrivions
les instructions, le pseudocode de la
tâche maintient votre fréquence cardiaque dans cette
plage
, puis il y a une prise de décision
avec le système moteur Skeletor, qu'il soit
capable d'action consciente
et d'étirement
ou plus euh subconscient
et ensuite agissant à travers  physiologie
du corps ou du monde extérieur qui
intercepte  L'estimateur d'état 5
s'aligne sur la
mise en œuvre souhaitée de la décision motrice squelettique
,
contrairement au rôle des
instructions de tâche, pour ainsi dire, qui est substitué
dans cette vue théorique du contrôle
avec l'estimateur de capacité allostatique
comme impératif et qui se nourrit à
travers un ensemble très similaire.  sur le
côté droit, mais ici, nous avons en fait le
contrôleur de décision du moteur des viscères,
contrairement à un
contrôleur de décision du moteur scalaire, car il est plus
axé sur le
choix du bouton gauche ou du
bouton droit et la figure six est davantage axée sur
le type de canon
point de vue de la théorie du contrôle réflexe mais qui
généralise aussi  noyau tout
comme les concepts perceptuels servent de
modèles internes du bo  Les
concepts d'action des surfaces sensorielles de dy servent également de
modèles internes de comportements potentiels et de leurs
résultats prédits. La
section 4.1 entraîne une
fonction objective SOC à partir de la
forme mathématique par laquelle la section 2 représentait les
courbes de capacité,
puis la section 4.2 4.3 et 4.4 sont
décrites en débusquant ce modèle apic.
ajouter
non allons-y d'accord 4.1
transformer les courbes de capacité en
fonctions objectives
puisque toute courbe de capacité donnée telle que
le 1 et la figure 1 ci-dessus
qui est une valeur maximale sur l'axe vertical,
elle peut être divisée par sa valeur y
maximale pour la normaliser à la plage  entre 0
et 1. une fois normalisé de cette manière, il
peut être interprété comme une fonction de
distribution cumulative de la
théorie des probabilités
c'est précisément en fait précisément ce que
srinivasan Laughlin et dubs ont
fait pour interpréter le déclenchement des
neurones rétiniens et des mouches comme une forme de
codage prédictif voir  il figure un
la dérivée d'une fonction de
distribution cumulative CDF donne une
probabi  fonction de densité de lité PDF de
sorte que la dérivée d'un CDF donne un
PDF c'est la manière la plus familière de
représenter une distribution de probabilité
où la hauteur sur l'axe vertical
correspond à la vraisemblance dans le PDF
mais pour un PDF dérivé d'une
courbe de capacité, il représente une
réactivité relative  à la perturbation, nous
appellerons une telle distribution une distribution de référence
, il s'agit donc d'une transformation des
distributions statistiques entre le
PDF qui est la
fonction de densité de probabilité et la fonction de distribution cumulative CDF
,
cela pourrait être très familier pour certains, cela
pourrait être totalement nouveau pour certains, donc c'est
tout bon  j'espère que cela est encore utile
pour considérer la relation entre les
deux,
donc ici, à gauche de ces trois
images, le PDF qui est la manière la plus
familière de représenter une
distribution de probabilité, nous dirions
qu'il s'agit d'une distribution uniforme, il y a
une chance sur six d'obtenir  chaque
résultat d'un dé à six faces
ou dans une situation de courbe en cloche
gaussienne qui  h ces deux
images du milieu et de droite montrent que
le PDF de la courbe en cloche est la
courbe en cloche donc le PDF est le plus
familier la distribution uniforme est comme une
ligne plate dans le PDF la courbe en cloche est
comme une courbe en cloche dans le PDF
mais puisque vous connaissez les valeurs maximales et
minimales, ne
serait-ce que de manière asymptotique,
vous pouvez créer une fonction de
distribution cumulative qui commence
fondamentalement aussi bas que la fonction peut prendre en
charge cette distribution et elle
s'accumule simplement de
manière cumulative, il est donc utile de répondre à la
question ce qui est  la probabilité d'
obtenir un quatre ou trois ou deux ou un
qui est des deux tiers ou quelle est la
probabilité d'obtenir un score z
inférieur à deux comme deux écarts-types
positifs quelle fraction de la courbe est
inférieure à ce score z sur le PDF  et qui
est adressable en recherchant
rapidement un point sur ce CDF,
il s'avère que cette relation
entre le PDF et le CDF qui est
plus familière à nouveau comme lancer un
dé ou évaluer comme  la hauteur dans une
salle de classe
peut être utilisée
sur la courbe de capacité discutée précédemment
pour passer à une distribution qui, lorsqu'elle
est maximisée, se trouve à cet
endroit du contrôle maximal,
donc ici, le CDF de la figure 2
obtient la dérivée, puis il devient
le PDF
avec euh ce genre de négatif
la forme de la courbe et c'est un peu ce à quoi on
faisait allusion avec cette
ligne orange maximisée La ligne orange
maximisée
est le point culminant de cette
courbe en cloche, mais ce n'est pas un
velcro classique mais c'est une montagne c'est un
pic que vous pouvez savoir de quel côté  vous êtes
sur et donc assez facilement optimisé
vers
um
pour la commodité analytique nous prenons la
pratique de tedorov 2006 d'utiliser une
densité de log le logarithme d'un PDF comme
fonction objectif plutôt que le PDF
lui
-même le point de fonctionnement continue alors à
apparaître comme maximum local  tandis que le gain
détermine le coût de l'éloignement
du point de fonctionnement et la valeur
du mouvement vers celui-ci la figure 8 montre
la fonction objectif log de  nsity
correspondant à la courbe de capacité originale du réflexe Barrel la
figure 9 clarifie davantage la
relation entre les différentes formes
de courbe de capacité en montrant les trois
côte à côte, c'est donc une très
belle figure en haut à gauche de la
figure est la figure un avec le réflexe
qui est composé ou composé pour
réguler la pression artérielle
qui est interprété comme un CDF
peut entraîner un PDF
et qui est un seul pic que vous pouvez
maximiser
au lieu d'essayer de calculer un
résidu
la forme de cette courbe devient légèrement
plus agréable pour optimiser le calcul
lorsque vous faites en sorte qu'il ressemble à un
bol plus lisse
plutôt qu'à ce genre de forme d'entonnoir inversé,
nous pouvons simplement entrer plus en détail pourquoi je pense
que ce sera cool pourquoi cette étape de journal
est-elle importante ou est-elle importante mais il suffit de
dire  que c'est le grand mouvement qui vous permet de
transformer l'
acte de jonglerie sigmoïde
en tableau d'ascension de montagne
on résume un tableau clé
on résume quelques notations clés
nous ne prétendons pas que notre modèle graphique
capture avec précision l'anatomie du
cerveau, il capture
le contrôle moteur sensoriel basé sur des références sur une hiérarchie
d'échelles de temps une seule caractéristique partagée
avec un cerveau
variables
dans un tableau les
équations cinq et six sur le
taux de capture instantané que
nous allons  discutez-en dans le point 1.2
section 4.2 sera également agréable d'en
discuter est la recherche de nourriture optimale La théorie suggère une
forme fonctionnelle pour le contrôle allostatique
voulez-vous ajouter quelque chose à l'avance
sur la recherche de nourriture optimale
autre que je veux Je veux parler
avec les auteurs  à propos de ce que
cela signifie même
que ce sera génial d'accord équation
huit
Taux de capture global
section 4.3 rétroaction ou
contrôle par anticipation avec action générative Concepts
, voici donc quelques formalismes supplémentaires et cela
ne relève pas du
cadre de la psychologie expérimentale
mais plutôt du cadre théorique du contrôle
avec  l'
estimateur de capacité allostatique à gauche
section 4.3
équation 10 équation 11.
plus de variables
stoc  contrôle optimal hastic SOC qui a été
mentionné plus tôt dans l'
équation 12.
figure 10. celui-ci sera agréable pour
discuter d'un modèle génératif hiérarchique
capturant plusieurs échelles de temps et
distributions de référence à chaque niveau
sans aborder les questions empiriques
sur les hiérarchies neuronales ici, nous employons
un modèle avec L égal  quatre modèles pour
correspondre à la figure six,
cela définit ce que certains de ces nœuds signifient,
mais l'axe des ordonnées augmente l'échelle de temps,
donc peut-être des choses plus lentes plus haut,
puis à droite se trouve le passage du temps,
alors à quoi cela vous fait-il penser
ou qu'est-ce qui est  comme une façon dont nous pouvons aborder
l'interprétation de cela
bien, je n'essaie pas d'être un Apple intelligent
mais je trouve intéressant que L4
vous donne pas mal d'
informations que je veux dire il y a
peut-être et ils parlent du  fait
qu'il y a plus de quatre niveaux mais
ils veulent se concentrer sur ceux-là pour moi je
veux dire où va mon cerveau est d'accord donc
nous avons l'eau nous avons la levure
nous avons le Houblon nous  vous avez les grains et
cela peut créer tout à
fait le produit,
vous pouvez donc ajouter du jus ou quoi que ce soit, mais
vous avez les quatre ingrédients de base, alors
maintenant, en parcourant le temps, qu'est-ce que cela
permet, encore une fois, ce serait bien pour eux  pour
séparer cela, car je
pense que même dans ce cas, il y a suffisamment de choses
pour
comprendre beaucoup de choses à
droite 4.4 contrôle de rétroaction avec
action générative Concepts il y a toujours l'
équation 13 équation 14. et puis une
belle citation lecteurs familiers avec le
traitement prédictif
et actif  l'inférence reconnaîtra la
forme de l'équation ci-dessus 14.
comme une énergie libre négative ou variationnelle
inférieure Liée à la discussion voir quelques
citations puisque les objectifs peuvent généralement
être écrits et interprétés de
plusieurs manières équivalentes Chacune
pouvant venir avec ses propres intuitions il
y a Arguments  pour l'efficacité informatique et
thermodynamique de la minimisation de
cette divergence spécifique au cours
du traitement neuronal, mais à ce jour, l'
avai  les preuves lables n'excluent pas d'
autres divergences d'informations plus complexes
pour pénaliser la
correction par rétroaction des mouvements
, il est donc assez intéressant de voir comment différentes
limites inférieures
variations des limites inférieures des énergies libres négatives
existent comme il y a de
l'énergie libre attendue, puis il y a de l'énergie libre
du futur attendu et il y a tout
de  ces variantes, puis chacune de ces
énergies peuvent être décomposées différemment
comme l'équation 2.6 dans le manuel
, il est donc
intéressant de voir d'abord comment
elles ont convergé vers ce type d'abondance
et pourquoi devrait-elle avoir une telle résonance
avec le principe de l'énergie libre
et qu'est-ce que cela fait  cela signifie
et ensuite comment différents partitionnements
de ces limites d'énergie peuvent-ils nous aider à penser
à des systèmes qui survivent.
de familiarité et je n'ai pas vraiment
lutté avec le genre d'étape de verrouillage
qu'ils traversaient,
mais  dès que nous sommes arrivés aux équations 13
et au saut aux équations 15 et 16.
quelqu'un de plus brillant que
moi devra être capable d'expliquer ce
saut en termes très simples parce
que même si je l'ai lu un certain nombre de
fois  Je ne sais toujours pas exactement comment cela
fonctionne, donc encore une fois, les auteurs voudront vraiment
apporter leurs leurs
leurs leurs gants les plus doux parce que j'ai besoin de mon
ordinateur de poche
ouais d'accord
section 4.4 toujours ici l'équation 15.
section 4.4 voici l'équation 16.
remplacer l'objectif augmenté
fantaisie
J
équation 14.
et l'expression analytique pour le
contrôleur de rétroaction optimal seul
équation 15 dans l'
équation 12 de l'équation de Bellman donnerait l'
équation 16. apprenons ce que c'est oui
maintenant le terme récursif insoluble dans
l'équation est
Etc
trouver un moyen de remplacer ceci  terme
donnera un problème plus calculable que
l'information Le terme de divergence dans la fantaisie
J fournit exactement de cette manière puisqu'il peut
être écrit aussi précisément que
la différence  entre le
maximum dur intraitable sous Q star star sub Phi
et le maximum lisse plus traitable
sous le concept d'action pré-planifiée dans l'
équation de symboles 17. assez intéressant d'
accord
euh s équation 17 à 21
puis la dernière section section cinq
discussion
peut-être que vous pouvez m'aider  aujourd'hui, nous sommes donc de 13
à 17, puis de 18 à 19 et 20, un
moyen de pouvoir assembler
certains des
formalismes sans échelle avec les détails spécifiques à l'échelle ou
adaptés à l'
échelle en particulier lorsque vous lisez
ceci, c'est ce que vous les avez vus  essayer de
clarifier
c'est une excellente
question
et donc vous parlez de global
et je pense qu'ils doivent être capables de l'
épeler et je pense que oui mais
encore une fois je suis je
suis c'était tout d'un coup les choses sont allées
dans le fossé pour moi
voici ce que je
m'aventurerais
dans la première section,
il y a un contraste entre l'
homéostasie et l'allostase
et sur la façon dont les systèmes de récompense ne sont
plus nécessaires dans certains
modèles distribués de neuroanatomie cérébrale
et une fonction
donc je crois que les
formalismes suivants substituent l'objectif augmenté
dans un
cadre d'optimalité et d'optimisation
comme l'équation de Bellman qui est souvent
utilisée pour la maximisation de la récompense donc je suis
récompensé en atteignant le sommet de la
montagne
donc je vais évaluer les chemins basés
sur la quantité de récompense qu'ils accumulent d'accord
, puis la curiosité ou ainsi de suite sera
précieuse dans la mesure où au fil du temps
Horizon que je
considérais comme facilitant la récompense en termes d'
élévation
alors que nous voyons ici le mouvement
vers cela comme la
maximisation
de la maniabilité optimale avec la relation pdfcdf
comme au lieu d'essayer de réduire la
divergence au point médian du CDF,
vous maximisez votre réactivité
en termes de maximisation du journal PDF d'accord,
donc je pense que c'est la
fonction de récompense augmentée
qui est traitable
et il reste ensuite du travail pour
spécifier cette fonction et comment elle  se comporte
peut-être
bien
alors l'interception de la discussion de la section cinq
stabilise l'action et
construit al  références perdues les
gens peuvent regarder les citations n'importe quoi
pour résumer ici
pas d'accord 5.1 considérer le cerveau comme un
contrôleur optimal
allostatique le modèle apic de contrôle intégral de chemin allostatique
dans la section 4 implique un certain nombre
d'hypothèses spécifiques Au-delà de celles
génériques à stochastiques Contrôle optimal
il y a quelques discussions  de
choix de modélisation partagés avec des modèles d'inférence actifs
peut-être suffisant pour qu'apic soit considéré comme
une sorte de modèle d'inférence actif
, puis quelques autres fonctionnalités qui sont
partagées avec des modèles d'inférence actifs au
sens strict s'il en existe un
et également des efforts de modélisation connexes
rien à ajouter
non  non, ils écrivent cela assez clairement
ici, vous voulez juste lire ce
droit, le 5.1 fournit quelques prédictions
et quelques contrastes avec le modèle apic
5.2
le corps et le cerveau à travers le prisme
de la théorie du contrôle la
figure six montre comment les données des sens
viscéraux montent en effet  pour devenir X
erreurs de prédiction interceptives afférentes
voulez-vous expliquer br  iefly ce que signifie un affluent X
parce que les gens pourraient expliquer
cela dans le glossaire mais c'est
essentiellement un signal apparent sur
un signal de fonctionnement il y a un peu de
récursivité
là-bas vous voulez ajouter n'importe quoi à cela
euh
je
vois la distinction
juste pour mettre en évidence ce qui y est afférent  est
afférent est conducteur ou conduit
vers l'intérieur ou vers quelque chose pour les
nerfs le système nerveux central pour les
vaisseaux sanguins l'organe fourni correctement
et euh
comment distingueriez-vous les efforts exacts
juste c'est juste que c'est ce genre de
cumulatif
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas en quelque sorte l'
initiale
est ce que j'en ai retenu l'
accumulation de ces signaux apparents
intéressant
je pense que vous vous trompez c'est ce que j'ai pris
cinq trois théories des courbes d'interception et de capacité
du codage prédictif périphérique
raison pour laquelle les
réponses les moins chères métaboliquement d'un neurone devraient
représenter les stimuli prévisibles
alors que cher  les réponses sont réservées
aux stimuli les plus surprenants
quelque prédiction  s et suggestions de
Barrett 2017
et les découvertes de dwark en 2013, certains
intercepteurs périphériques et humains
réduisent leur taux de tir opérant à zéro
sous un stimulus constant,
donc c'est assez intéressant comme si aucun
changement
ne m'en parle et cela devrait
être bon marché sous  un modèle où quelque
chose change moins souvent qu'autrement
euh et il y a d'autres hypothèses euh que
nous avons émis l'hypothèse que l'
augmentation de cette réactivité qui
est l'impératif de ce modèle apic
pourrait fonctionner comme des récompenses
renforçant positivement les trajectoires comportementales
tandis que la diminution de la réactivité pourrait
fonctionner comme des coûts négatifs  renforcer
les trajectoires comportementales
afin de garder les options ouvertes sur le
temps infini Horizon devient équivalent
à maintenir l'entreprise flottante ou à
maintenir la physiologie limitée
ouais
la
continuité étrangère au lieu de simplement maximiser la
quantité d'USD ou de calories,
mais plutôt d'avoir réduit ou
limité la surprise d'une gamme et d'une
trajectoire et  une stratégie
non  dans ce modèle comme indiqué ici
pour générer que
5.3 courbes d'interception et de capacité
plus
5.4 conclusions enfin nous revenons au
joueur amateur de ballon chasseur
la fourmi mature ouais et
euh quelques résumés du modèle apic
et des suggestions sur sa compatibilité
avec une hypothèse de contrôle référent
et certains de  sa maniabilité
c'est la discussion puis l'annexe B
climatisation
dont nous avons déjà parlé mais c'est une
sorte de sujet sympa donc juste pour
sauter ces annexes juste en
discuter avec les auteurs nous espérons alors euh
quelques équations supplémentaires dans l'équation B
formulant la prescription et  le contrôle
aérodiquement conduit au
principe de l'énergie libre fep
plus de l'annexe B annexe C
détails de la dérivation du modèle apic
équations
C 0.1.2 dérivation complète de la fonction de valeur optimale
et de la transition Dynamique plus d'
équations
la forme intégrale de chemin pour la
fonction de désirabilité de la valeur donne son nom à
la technique  de contrôle intégral de chemin
et ainsi de suite une sorte de note de clôture que
nous  se demandait comment cela se connectait à la
mécanique bayésienne
et à la formulation du chemin le
plus à droite des trois
faces de la mécanique bayésienne
et comment venant potentiellement d'
un point de départ assez différent
et avec des
approches et des contraintes différentes,
certaines caractéristiques similaires
auraient pu apparaître et être mises
en évidence dans apic
qui sont également mis en évidence et pertinents
pour la mécanique bayésienne dans la formalisation du chemin
et peut-être qu'il y a comme
une sorte de diagramme de Venn non cartographié
là-bas et quelques similitudes et
différences la
proximité avec le dernier flux en direct,
que ce soit par accident ou par intention,
fait de
la façon dont vous regardez  cet article
euh
intéressant je dirai juste
ouais
était bien d'accord avec tout
ce que vous voulez
conclure avec
je pense que l'idée de pouvoir
regarder un mod à la modélisation et à la
modélisation interne et en quelque sorte la coordination de
cela soit
encore une fois au moins deux  autre comme
un exercice de gestion ou de minimisation des risques
donc une stratégie de limitation
ou comme une option gen  erating ou une
stratégie d'expansion serait quelque chose de
vraiment intéressant à discuter avec les
auteurs car encore une fois, je ne
peux pas vraiment savoir si
le modèle apic fonctionne ou non dans les deux domaines
jusqu'à ce que je dépasse le saut entre le
formalisme 13
et tous  le chemin jusqu'à 17 18 19 à 20.
mais je veux dire avec une explication de cela
et euh et un et une douce incitation, il serait
intéressant de savoir
comment cela fonctionne lorsque ces choses semblent
être, que ce soit nous en tant
qu'entités physiologiques  sont capables de jongler à la fois avec la
gestion des risques et l'
expansion de l'option de générateur d'options d'options, donc je suis
vraiment très excité à ce sujet à
partir d'un
voici ce que je ressens comment devrais-je
lire cela en termes de ce que je peux
jusqu'où je peux faire mon  Prochain pari
d'un point de vue allostatique, je pense
que c'est
vraiment excitant si vous si, comme je l'ai dit, si
je peux avoir
une meilleure idée de la façon dont ce saut fonctionne dans
leur modèle
[Musique]
ouais vraiment intéressé par cet
horizon temporel infini et cette
mentalité comme
w  c'est la meilleure
décision physiologique sur l'Horizon infini,
attendez c'est une excellente question et ouais
l'Éternel maintenant
la présence
et puis euh aussi un peu plus
banalement comme quel type de données
sont pertinentes pour ce type de modèle
est-ce des données qui existent déjà pour
les gens
est-ce quelque chose où vous pouvez
extrapoler beaucoup à partir d'un ensemble de données clairsemé
ou avez-vous besoin d'un tas de réplications pour
obtenir une bonne confiance statistique sur le
paramètre du modèle et extraire des résultats
qui sont comme non triviaux
et où cette
technologie ou approche est-elle utilisée  ou
où pourrait-il être utilisé, il y a
beaucoup de choses dont il sera intéressant de
parler,
merci pour toute la préparation et l'
aide sur celui-ci Dean et à bientôt dans le
point un et au-delà d'accord mon ami
prends soin de toi au revoir